we want to we wanted to bring a clip so
we can't we're just going to show you
the episode hey youtubers this charlie
welcome to my spoiler review of the
first episode of Joss Whedon's agents of
shield that's right I elbowed my way
through line for eight hours and was
rewarded with the very first episode of
shield it wasn't without his problems
they did actually go up and down the
aisles with these laser beams pointed in
people's eyes just to make sure you
weren't recording stuff but don't worry
I'm gonna do a full review so you'll
know everything that I know I also
posted the full panel footage online too
so you can find out what the actors had
to say and what Joss Whedon had to say
they mostly use the panel to talk about
all the new actors on the show obviously
they're not really focusing so much on
the superheroes it's really about
regular people so think of it as more of
like an office action slash comedy just
because Joss Whedon does that so well so
the setup for the episode was actually
really funny just Whedon actually came
out you know with everyone they
introduced all the actors and he said
well we were gonna show off a clip but
why don't we just show you the whole
episode so obviously the audience went
crazy and that's when all the laser
beams came out Zed turn your cameras off
the episode starts off with J August
Richards character and his son and
obviously this is post Avengers so we
see a lot of superheroes and his son is
lingering on a lot of these action
figures so you get a lot of imagery from
the Marvel Universe and if you've seen
the clips and the teasers you see the
scenes where J August Richards rescues
that person from the burning building
and just jumps you know all the way off
the top of the building to the ground
that's basically like the opening scene
during that scene Chloe Bennet who
basically plays like this tech genius on
the show catches him doing it and
basically tracks them down and learns
his identity so obviously the shield
agents are trying to find J August
Richards and learn who he is and try and
help him but they can't do it so they
basically need Chloe Bennet's character
to help them track them down but before
they get there we actually meet Bret
Dalton's character he's kind of like the
James Bond II quarterback of the show on
the panel Joss Whedon actually said that
this is Bret Dalton's very first TV job
ever so high-five to him for landing a
Joss Whedon show
an ABC show and a Marvel show as a bit
of a trifecta but we basically find out
that Breton Dalton's character is like
this lone wolf character and a big part
of his art is actually learning to work
with the cord shield team which we kind
of meet throughout the course of the
episode we also meet some people from
the Whedon verse which is really cool if
you remember Shepherd book from Firefly
he's actually a doctor in shield
headquarters and Cobie Smulders is in
the episode two so get excited her
actually last season on How I Met Your
Mother is happening this year so there's
a good chance that she'll be in a lot of
episodes going forward next we get some
references about agent Coulson's death
is actually Brett Dalton learns that
Agent Coulson isn't dead as he's brought
into the core shield team and although
they don't explain how Coulson survived
there are some lines from Cobie Smulders
that lead me to believe that he's either
say like a clone with transplanted
consciousness or memories or a life
model decoy like a lot of people believe
personally I think there's more credence
to the clone theory but you can let me
know what you think if you either saw
the pilot or when the episode eventually
airs know Coulson actually sends the
core shield team off to find Chloe
Bennet and bring her into the fold since
she's basically set up as this person
who can be smarter than they are
obviously rather than capture her and
detain her Coulson decides that it's
more effective to turn her and turned
her into a SHIELD agent one of the big
things this Chloe Bennet characters
actually used for too is is providing an
inn for new viewers into the Marvel
Universe so obviously remember this is a
Disney show on a Disney Network so they
wanted to appeal to as many people as
possible so Chloe Bennet's character is
basically used to kind of explain a lot
of the technical jargon or maybe some of
the Marvel Easter eggs that people who
haven't read the comics might not
understand and like I mentioned earlier
this is technically the Whedon verse
even though Joss Whedon isn't running
the show he's really just an executive
producer
so Chloe Bennett actually helps provide
some of the early comedic beats there's
also some scenes between her character
and Bret Dalton's character to lead me
to believe that there'll be some
shipping going on this season although
if you watched a lot of just Whedon
series in the past you know sometimes it
takes a long time for those kinds of
relationships to develop so I don't
think they're gonna be hooking up
anytime soon but just based on what I've
seen I kind of think that they're
basically kind of pair off eventually so
as we get to learn more in the episode
about
J August Richards character we find out
that he's basically just a normal guy
who lost his job due to an injury and a
mystery doctor told him that they could
make him stronger and basically the
mechanism they use is the Iron Man three
extremists obviously he's really strong
now but the threat is is that if he
can't control his power so basically
explode and kill a bunch of people so
he's also got this caterpillar on his
arm and even though that sheet re they
don't really explain too much how the
sheet re tech affects his extremist
powers so obviously the episode ends on
a high note but we don't really know if
we're gonna see J August Richards in the
future of the series personally I think
we will see him he might not be in every
episode but they'll be tracking down
different people and all these different
episodes obviously that's basically like
the core mission they're basically like
the x-files Meets Buffy so it'll be like
you know a lot of weird sci-fi stuff
going on with a lot of humorous beats I
don't know how it felt about the use of
extremists in the episode it felt like
they were kind of taking the easy path
honestly I really think they did that
just because there's so much of a
popular awareness of extremists because
of Iron Man 3 so I think that was more
of a strategic decision rather than
something that they thought was cool one
of the really badass characters that we
meet in the show is ming-na they don't
really fully explain this dark past or
character has but we do learn that she
basically has this really dangerous
history and I think they're gonna use
all of season one just like the the
Coulson survival story to kind of
explain who she is and why she is the
way she is overall I really love the
show and I'm definitely going to be
watching it every week I'll be doing
weekly shield videos be sure to
subscribe them as soon as it comes it's
gonna be coming late in September so
that's around the same time that Legend
of Korra comes so there's gonna be a ton
of awesome TV content on my channel so
get really excited honestly one of the
big lingering questions though is the
survival of Agent Coulson how did he
survive is he a life model decoy is the
a clone is the cyborg is he's something
else let me know what you think right
below in the comments honestly I think
they're gonna take the rest of the
season to explain that mystery and it's
just gonna be tied up in all this
re tech and whoever this big villain is
whether it's aim or some other evil
organization or even just a person
overall the tone that I got from Joss
Whedon on the comic-con panel was is
that he's really focusing on the
corecast it has virtually nothing to do
with the superheroes in the Marvel
Universe it's really about just this
core team of shield members they're just
gonna come together and try and solve
these problems together in other news
I'm also going to be doing a lot of
Breaking Bad videos there's only eight
episodes left in the season and it's
going to premiere this Sunday so I'll be
doing recaps each week so get real
excited you still have time to catch up
even though I'm going to VidCon this
weekend I'll try to post a Breaking Bad
preview just to catch everyone up really
quickly if you do happen to see me at
VidCon be sure to give me high five I'll
totally give you a high five back in the
meantime though check out my review of
the Doctor Who 50th anniversary trailer
from Comic Con by clicking here it was
totally awesome and learn about all the
new characters that are coming to Game
of Thrones season 4 by clicking here
thanks for watching high fives for
everyone big con high fives see you
later bye
you